foreign
years ago I was a cyclist hit by a truck
very very injuries yeah how can I
rebuild my resilience when time and
obligations keep beating me down how
honest can I be with you Barry you're
not gonna like it Chantelle
[Music]
what is going on this is John with a Dr
John deloney show
my favorite mental health and
relationship and marriage and parenting
podcast
I would hope it's actually it's not even
my favorite there's a couple others that
are way better but I'm still glad
Kelly's like what are you talking about
this is my show hey I'm so glad that
you're with us um here's here's the
premise of the show real people going
through real stuff in real time and my
promise is I'll sit with you and I'll
walk alongside you as we figure out
what's the next right move what's the
next thing we're gonna do here
um and it could be around your your
mental health Diagnostics it could be
around dealing with trauma dealing with
loss dealing with marriage issues with
parenting whatever's going on in your
world my promises I'll tell you the
truth and we'll walk alongside each
other
um if you want to be on the show go to
John deloney.com ask a-s-k John
deloney.com
ask and um man I'd love you having a
show leave a write it write a message
write it write a uh what's going on in
your life and it goes to Jenna and Kelly
and then they will get you on the show
all right let's go out to Edmonton
Canada and talk to Elaine what's up
Elaine
well well played Elaine well played I
hope that felt good
what's up what's up um well
um so my husband recently had a
psychotic break
um ended up in a
um mental facility for a couple weeks
um he's now out
um how do I help him work through some
of the craziness of that time and how to
I and our kids deal with what happened
yeah it's scary tell me about it what
happened
um
it's okay take a breath take a breath
you're all good
did it happen in your home
um sort of
um so hold on I just want to acknowledge
for everybody if you've never been
around this if you never
um
seeing somebody you care about
have a psychotic break or if you've
never been with somebody it's terrifying
right it's like out of a movie
scary scary scary stuff and you see the
person that you love and care about
right in front of you and they are gone
and it is scary right
yeah like
um
one of the nurses in the first second
hospital we went to
um make sure you just can't make this
stuff up like a discount
um hey do me a favor Elaine you talk
directly into the phone for me okay
that's okay
yeah no I
have it away from my ear yeah anyways
um so yeah so he there's been a lot of
uh stressors over the last
few years but particularly in the last
couple months
um
and so like I would say it was brought
on by lack of sleep you talk about how
important sleep is I cannot stress bad
enough
um
in the end he was
sleeping Maybe
between one and a half to three hours a
night living on caffeine and energy
drinks
um not a good
thing
yeah that's tough for your body to
handle
yeah and
you know so give a little bit of History
he had lost
he'd lost his job due to covet at the
end of 21.
um got a near the job in 22. he ended up
getting laid off from that one in
January of 23 and had just started a new
job in March and it was
um it was a good job but very very
stressful right he enjoyed it but like I
said there was a lot of stress around it
um and that was just one of multiple
things and Canada's been particularly
difficult over the last few years right
yeah we won't even go there
here's like I I
um some psychotic breaks are are brought
on by like a schizophrenic diagnostic
right it's not the diagnosis it doesn't
but you have a schizophrenic mind
um or you've got some
some
alterations in your neurochemistry in
your brain right other psychotic breaks
are brought on by you don't sleep for
two months and you live off you know uh
adenosine antagonist you live off
caffeine and it makes you
um it Alters the reality of your brain
right and one day you wake up and it's
you're you've to
an ugly way of saying is that you
snapped right and your body checks out
it loses touch with reality over time
and so there's and there's a long
Spectrum in between that but what's
important is also there's a context
there is an and there's a ecosystem
where this is all taking place and we we
often forget that right it's like the
couple who calls or the the mom who
calls and says
um my marriage is falling apart and then
they tell me they have four kids under
the age of seven well it's like well
it's not your marriage didn't find a
part your house is insane and so being a
candidate over the last three years has
been really really hard and if you are
listening to this going what I don't
know anything about that just go back
and check it out there's been all this
government Clash if you think California
is bad what they what can't Canada's had
to endure has been Madness and you put
that on top of a bunch of job loss on
top of on top of on top of and now you
get a recipe right for yeah you lose
your husband so what when he went to the
psych ward staying standard Award for
two weeks tells me there was some pretty
significant things going on that wasn't
just a three-day get some sleep and get
some food in you and
let's get you uh like a
uh a treatment plan at home what was
going on
last week before but of course we've
never been through this before
um we've been married almost 36 years so
it's not like
you know I didn't know him or anything
um
and so yeah the last week things started
getting very odd very weird and then he
went to on the weekend it was
things started really going off the
rails he kind of lost it on me which in
a way that isn't normal for him
whatsoever
um but when he got when he got when he
got to the hospital did they give him a
diagnosis of anything
well no see he left work early on uh on
the Monday and then he responding to me
on the phone and then he kind of went
off the grid we had no idea where he was
um eventually he
was
climbing on a Ledge and stuff in a car
wash and so they called 9-1-1 and the
cops and he had no ID on him he got to
the hospital and I'm looking all over
for him I thought I knew where he'd gone
but he hadn't got there to this remote
place where he wanted just some time
alone
um
and
so he was in the hospital for
about two hours I think before I got a
call
um
and then when I got there he had been
sedated and when he
came to he was mostly himself like not
100 obviously
um the doctor came in talked to him for
a bit
okay originally they said they were
going to have us like evolved on and
then he released him to me
um because he was doing so well
the moment he said they were going to
release him he started going off a
little bit
um
but we went home
and you know knowing that sleep is an
issue he went to sleep and then
um this sounds really odd but he'd been
walking around infield for like three
hours before that and so just as he went
to sleep discovered some ticks and so
like the insect okay and so I started
dealing with that and of course then he
was woke up and
um
he started panicking it's not safe it's
not safe can't be here it's not safe and
our one son lives to just
we have an acreage but we're on the edge
of town
and our son lives basically a couple
doors down and he took off running and
went to his house so ultimately he was
put back in the hospital for an Extended
Stay did they give him a diagnosis of
bipolar disorder of schizophrenia that
it would be a strange to me this late
but
they ultimately just said he needed some
sleep he burned himself out completely
just detached from reality for a while
they did toss around bipolar a little
bit but
um
it doesn't really stick the diagnosis
because it's not like going back right
so tell me tell me I'm trying to get to
how I can help you now so when they
discharged him what did they tell you
well
a very difficult question
um all right did he not sign a release
he signed a release but I don't think it
says in there anything about
bipolar
um well well so here's here's step one
okay
if if he is on the same page with you is
he on the same page with you
yeah okay he needs to contact his mental
health provider the doctors who are with
him and I don't know how Canada's system
works they would have given you a social
worker here in the states to help you
navigate everything so whenever one of
my students would go into a psych ward I
would go sit the first person I would
talk to is the social worker who helps
them navigate all the different doctors
and people coming in and out and
have him sign a release that says I need
you to tell my wife everything
that you found and to walk her through
what my next steps can be so she can be
and here's the magic word she can be an
advocate for me
and yeah I I did was able to talk with a
social worker involved but when I would
start asking some of the more medical
side of things uh she wasn't as clear as
what I could have hoped for so he did
sign a release when he was there so that
I could get information and are all the
fun as well okay um so I would re I
would re-establish a meeting with her
now that he's been home for a little bit
and ask her some very pointed questions
very direct
um how many hours a night should he
sleep should he have access to the
internet is is caffeine completely off
the table it like
make them
with as kind as you can be make them
give you a Outpatient Treatment protocol
and that's the magic words Outpatient
Treatment protocol you are his Advocate
you're walking alongside him and they
might say he needs to go see a counselor
he's had a lot of job loss which is very
tough he's had a very tough run of it in
the last few years
um and so what we're gonna do is we're
the first thing we're gonna do is we're
going to come up with the plan
the second thing is both you and him
have to recognize
the Free Fall Terror that is losing
control of your own body
it's scary to see that in yourself to
think I did what I did all those things
and the police are describing where they
got you and you have no memory of that
you don't know what you're talking about
um or he has a little bit of a memory
and it terrifies him and then for you
he's your rock he's the guy
and if he can suddenly find himself
climbing on top of a car wash and not
know how he got there
the question you're suddenly the ice I
mean the sidewalk you walk on it becomes
very thin eyes right it's hard to put
your foot down I don't want to set him
off I don't want to do the wrong thing
what do I say what do I do yeah see what
I'm saying yeah does that does that
sound right
yeah absolutely yeah so if you have this
plan together
the second step is y'all build a new
marriage
how long 36 years in is that what you
said
in a couple weeks yeah congrats this is
a perfect time
now you can
build something completely new with the
knowledge that hey man like you found
out how far you can be pushed and we
found it I'm glad we're grateful that we
know this who are we going to become now
and you you might become people who turn
the TV off at 4 P.M and y'all just sit
on the front porch and talk to each
other and play cards and whatever you
might become people who take walks every
day and y'all are both in bed with the
lights out
at nine o'clock and you used to never be
the you should be out dancing well this
is a new thing we're building now does
that make do you see what I'm saying and
let give him a Content we're a couple
who every night we check in with each
other
how are you feeling today what are you
thinking today you just give each other
a few minutes of space to talk
so normally the things that are highly
highly therapeutic Therapeutics kind of
a dramatic word
are healing at home after these moments
are things like skin to skin contact
things like I Want to Hold Your Hand for
um 30 seconds every morning and I'm
Gonna Hold Your Hand 30 seconds when you
get home from work I just want to hold
you can I just hug you for 30 seconds
and we'll count it out
the reason I'm hesitating to give you
anything like that is I that might be
what sets off his psychosis and so
without looking at the doctor's report
it's I don't want to give you a bunch of
things to do
I think the key will be him Having the
courage to tell you what he needs on a
given day and you having The Bravery
courage to listen to him and then to
love him and here's the hard part
you tell him what you need and don't
treat him with a glass slipper do the
opposite give him some purpose and a
role inside that house and it will
anchor him see what I'm saying
and that's hard right now it's very hard
because you you wanna you wanna touch
everything with a velvet glove right you
want to be very careful not to set
anything off and if I just say the wrong
thing or move the wrong thing
and what that does is that puts his body
back on high alert because the one
anchor he's got is you and you're acting
different you're acting scared and
anxious and and so it just becomes this
this repeating cycle here
whereas you say hey I love you and and
when you take the trash out can you help
me out
I can be such a gift
see what I'm saying yeah like right now
like we we've had some of those
discussions you know where I've told
them like I'm on high alert for him
right because
I don't ever want to go down this path
again he doesn't want to go down this
path again
um it was pretty traumatic to stay in
there that's right um
terrifying in there yes
yeah like as he says it's a very dark
place there yes it's a scary Darkness
yes it is it is and
you know there's
there's good that has come of it already
um in terms of you know him
understanding
more being more compassionate toward
people who are dealing with stuff like
that yeah but that's all external and he
needs to be very passionate with him
yeah and I think he's finally getting
there to where he is being more
open with himself and and you know I've
listened to your show for quite a while
and you talk about you know
asking your spouse what do you need from
me and I have asked that over and over
and he often says I don't know I don't
know I don't know
um
and I've noticed he's starting to be
able to say those things this is what I
need right now and so let me say this
and this is for you and for everybody
and that's awesome and you kept in here
here's an important thing you kept
showing up and you kept showing up and
you kept showing up
most people will say what do you need
today I don't know Bill no hey how can I
love you today I don't know and they
never ask again and that's not you you
kept showing up you kept showing up you
kept showing up and eventually
when he realized oh I need a lot you
were there because you had laid off
you'd laid up like a brick road that he
could walk on
also if the question what do you need
what do you need after a week after two
weeks
if they don't have an answer to that
maybe ask a different question
put your hand on his chest
and say where are you where are you
tense today
where are you anxious today is it your
shoulders is it in your chest is it in
your forearms like where is it today is
it on your feet
and tell him where it is on you and
here's what we're doing we're getting to
the base layer because sometimes uh and
I'm guilty of this sometimes we turn
um what do you need today what do you
need today in a transaction of activity
what do you need today I need this this
and this all right I'll do those three
things what do you need today I need
this this and this
all that is great but that sits that's
not the that's not the base layer that
sits on top of
I see you
and I'm with you
and I'm here for you
and those three things are so grounding
and it makes it very challenging for a
body to be in chaos when that is
connected with other people in that
rooted way
who
and so it may be what do you need to do
what do you need today what do you need
today Bam
where are you so maybe you shift the
question where are you scared today what
are you scared about today
what do you really give me one thing you
got to give me one thing you're really
excited about today
what is one
hot romantic thing we can do today you
get one and I get one what is one
physical activity we can do today like
begin to Branch it out a little bit and
give him some
um some cues there but all this let's be
clear all of this is going to stem from
all these activities at home are going
to stem from you going back to the the
social worker
and really pressing on an outpatient
treatment plan
what based on y'all's expertise all
these doctors and all these tests and
two weeks in a psych ward well I don't
know how it is in Canada in the US would
be very expensive because there would be
a million different
um professionals that came in and out of
there
um
in y'all's expertise what are some
things that my husband needs
and you and him go away and build like
just dream together we got scared we got
scared whoa we made it we're here we're
back
here's my promise to you Elaine walking
around all tents
arms clinched hands clenched chest
clinched heart clinched is a recipe for
a very anxious house and the goal here
is to create a non-anxious house okay
non-anxious house
so um hang on the line here I'm going to
send you two decks of both of the
couples questions for humans and this is
just something you and him can do y'all
can make a ritual out of it and there's
52 cards in each deck this can get you
104 days and every day you can just sit
down and agree to do one card together
over uh I was gonna say over coffee
probably not over over warm warm water
and chamomile tea but y'all can have
this conversation together and it's and
again we are bridging back to one
another
we're going to follow this treatment
plan and we're gonna figure out creative
ways to ask each other how can I love
you today
what does that look like what does it
feel like what does that taste like how
can I love you today he is really really
lucky to have you Elaine I know this is
a scary scary scary season
I hate that for y'all if you've never
been to a psych ward folks it is a scary
dark place
it's scary when you lose trust in your
own body it's scary when you lose trust
and the person who is the anchor of the
family
this is the moment when you can you can
do one or two things you can walk away
from the collapse of the building
or y'all can exhale
and be sad and grieve it and then ask
yourselves what are we going to build
next we'll be right back
good folks slowing down is a critical
aspect of mental health calming music
prayers meditation they're all great
ways to find peace and hallow makes it
easy to start a daily practice of
meditation hallow is the number one
Prayer app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to journaling hallow makes it
easy to practice prayer meditate and
build a deeper more meaningful spiritual
life and ReDiscover true peace go to
hallow.com deloney today to get three
months of hollow for free
hallow.com deloney
all right we're back let's go to Eric in
Winchester what's up Eric
how you doing Dr John party any money
what are you up to
oh no I must just take him a break at
work there you go
what's up man how can I help
I also want to say before we start I
want to say thank you because over the
last few months you've really been a a
big factor in my personal development
and I appreciate you taking my call
today well I'm grateful for you
listening man and um never forget I'm
just a clown on a podcast or on YouTube
man you're the one actually having to
make hard choices every day so Props to
you brother it's awesome
so what's happening I got one that's
pretty big today and um it's something
I've kind of been stuck on but I really
need some some advice all right hey do
me a favor talk directly into your phone
okay
can you hear me now sir perfect that's
awesome fantastic
so um over the course of my life my uh
my father has not been the best husband
to my mother he is constantly you know
been
I'd say disrespectful towards her and
he's always had extra marital things
going on
um and it's kind of as I've gotten older
and I've had a son there are things that
he's done that I've vowed to never do
and it kind of become part of a moral
code for me like
cheating lying those are two really big
things for me that are absolute no gays
um so my question is today is that uh
it's not a Crossroads where I'm trying
to figure out if I should remove my
father from my life
because of the way he treats my mother
or if I should stay out of her marriage
problems
um I think there's a third option
I think that you were if you weaponize
your son
as a way to intervene in their marriage
that's a no-go
okay that's a way to get your kid burned
that's a way to get to it's just a way
to get your mom and more mass
um if you choose
to only have men of character in your
son's life
then you can look at your dad and he has
opted out of your son's life because of
the way he's chosen to live
and so that's a different proposition if
you
this would be a very difficult
conversation to have but if you sat down
and looked across the table and said Dad
um and by the way I would use very
specific language not you know you've
had some extramarital thing you've
cheated on my mom
and I will never know what was going on
behind closed doors I don't know how she
treated you behind closed I mean I don't
know any of that stuff I know you
cheated on my mom over and over and over
again I know you don't tell the truth
all the time
and I'm committed to having only men in
my son's life who are middle character
and now the choice is on you you could
have that call that conversation with
your old man it would be a powerful
conversation it probably will not go
well
um
but man it would be one where you would
walk real tall
and if you just especially if you did it
in a respectful dignified way not on the
back end of a fight like oh yeah y'all
are for Bush tall boys into a fight and
you're like oh you I tell you don't do
it like that but if you went down and
had a man-to-man conversation it could
be pretty incredible
but if you
say you can't see my grandson until you
treat my mom right then then you're
using your your son as a pawn and now
now it's just gonna make a mess
yeah I can I completely understand I
I decided to to call in to ask you for
your opinion because I consulted with
other men that I could consider of uh
integrity and high value and it was kind
of a split decision
um one one of the men that I consulted
with they suggested to not get involved
in marriage problems that are you know
that I'm not a part of the marriage and
then another individual that I consulted
with he had said that if you made a
commitment to only only allowing certain
types of people in your life
whether they're your parent or not does
not justify or excuse their behavior and
that's where it's been really
conflicting with me because with my
friends or cousins or whoever if you
cheat
uh on your spouse or your girlfriend or
boyfriend whoever may be
there is something inside me that says
well if you're not going to tell them I
am and if I lose your relationship if I
lose a relationship with you because of
it then I'm okay with that and my dad's
kind of been the exception for so long
because he's my dad and it does
it does not feel right anymore but it's
never felt right but it just feels like
our relationship is broken and wounded
because of these decisions
and he's actually taken me with him when
I was younger
um
when he was doing when he was cheating
with my mother before and um so that was
honestly
go ahead
that was honestly the hardest thing to
unpack and actually your show actually
helped me unpack that because
um for a long time it was really hard to
accept that
she did that and then two days later I
had to go see my mom and basically I'm
soaking out at 13 to lie to her that you
know basically cover up for him you know
yeah I
foreign
I'm nervous about you channeling that
inner pain what your dad did to you
sucks man what your dad did to you is is
immoral and it's wrong and like you said
a grown-up put a 13 year old in in a
very precarious position and now how old
are you
I'm 28 sir you're 28 man you're still
beating up that 13 year old for not
having more courage you gotta you gotta
lay off that 13 year old man
that's tough
that was Madness
because you know as well as I do
it you can look back now and be like I
should have done this I should have done
this but you're looking back now through
a 28 year old man's body
that 13 year old would have got his head
knocked off
or if he didn't mom might have
and so you gotta you gotta let that 13
year old off the hook because what's
turning what's happening is you're
turning into Batman you're turning into
a vigilante
and you were playing God over other
people's relationships my rule of thumb
is if I've got somebody in my life that
has an ongoing affair with somebody
I am choosing to not be around them
if they're somebody Ops me into this
conversation
let's say
um I'll make up something uh close buddy
of mine
let's say he's cheating on somebody for
a long long time he's got a year of fear
going on with somebody at work
and his wife calls me
and said I think something's going on
I know you love my husband I know y'all
are close
but I feel like something's wrong
something's going off the rails what I
would do is I would call my buddy and
say your wife has brought me into this
and she's somebody I care for and be
willing to lay down my life for as well
because she's in our gang you got 48
hours because I'm not gonna lie to your
wife
but if she doesn't bring me into that
I'm not gonna go around nuking things
because I have this inner 13 year old
that is so pissed at himself for not
defending his mom
over 15 years ago
but I am going to opt out a relationship
with that person I'm not gonna hang out
with that guy because I don't hang out
with guys like that
yeah and you see how you see how in my
voice how simple it is
you know what I mean it's just an it's
just an opt out and if one of my buddies
screwed up and had a one night stand or
found himself like head over heels for
somebody for a month at work I would sit
with him man I'm not gonna abandon you
in that
but also if somebody's having an affair
for over a year they would know they
know me right they're my they're my
friend they know what my opinion is
going to be on that they know I'm not
going to mince words about that and so
that's number one number two is
this is hard for what I'm about to say
okay
but your mom didn't invite you into this
if your mom had called you and said I
need help your dad's out of control
that's one thing
but you were deciding I'm gonna out
adult my mom and she has had her reasons
over the years for staying with a guy
that cheats on her all the time
she's had her reasons for staying with a
scumbag for all these years do you know
what those reasons are
um
she tells me it's because she loves them
and they've been together for so long
that she can't see herself being with
anybody else I hate what I'm about to
tell you
but she gets to make that choice she's
an adult
that's that's what one of the
individuals that
the individual that I talked to about
staying out of it that's what he said
she's a grown-up
your choice is as another grown-up what
are me and my house gonna do
who are we gonna be
and that's a harder conversation it's
actually easier in a way to throw
grenades
because the explosion is over there
it's somewhere else and you can feel
very self-righteous in doing so because
there's harm being done
but if someone doesn't invite you in
someone doesn't look at you and say help
then it's kind of impaired and it's
Madness and then you got to deal with
your own home and that hurts man it's a
bummer
yeah my mom's uh she's coming to me
often you know asking these things you
know asking what I should do or asking
them for a device but she's never she
did not open this particular door I
opened it right
and I don't and now that we're talking
about it
um as much as I want
I feel like you're right I feel like I
was
I was weaponizing the relationship with
my dad and my son because I feel like
that's something he would do
and you see how it happened you see how
it happens without us realizing it
yeah your old man weaponized you against
your mom when he was out carousing
and yeah that's for sure in a very
similar context you have taken your son
and put him right in the same line it's
just a different line
and your dad I promise you
has some moral reason he has convinced
himself however delusional and deranged
it is he's convinced himself well she
never does this and she's always doing
this and so I need to I work hard I need
a little you know a little fun on the
side every once in a while he's got a
reason
and then strangely and weirdly
and this is how family trauma just rolls
downhill without us even realizing it
yeah and that's what I'm trying that's
what I'm trying to stop I'm trying to
I've already committed that yeah I I
I've forgetting my dad for what he's
done like I don't beat him up over I
don't bring it up I don't ask him for an
apology because the thing is it's like
um
I I've heard you know things they said
like there's nothing that can really be
done about the past like technology is
not going to help and it's well apology
would go a long way if your old man
collagen said I was wrong I was wrong
I'm sorry that would be that'd be huge
like make no mistake that that would be
therapeutic in a way that would be hard
to describe
but I want you to pay very close
attention to the world you've created
can I be super direct with you is that
cool
yeah yeah
so you have in in protecting the tiny
cocoon that is your wife and you have
one kid or two kids how many kids you
got
um well I'm I'm not married okay I I I
have one son he's he's four years old
okay so you got you and your son it's
you against the world right and you've
decided I am not going to be a guy that
cheats I'm not I'm not going to be a guy
that lies I'm not
but I am going to tell anytime I see it
anywhere around me I'm gonna pick up the
phone I'm gonna pick up my social media
I'm gonna tell their spouse I'm gonna
tell their girlfriend I'm gonna tell
everybody
and in a weird way you've repeated your
dad's insistence on blowing up families
you've just decided to do it to other
people instead of your own
but the impulse is the exact same
and so healing looks like a true
forgiveness and you haven't forgiven
your old man because that 13 year old is
still playing Batman out there
number one you gotta let your old man go
and that doesn't mean that doesn't mean
washing your hands of it he was terrible
to you and I don't like talking about
other people's parents but your dad was
rough on you man
put you through the worst
and the second thing is
instead of being somebody who blows up
other people's marriages for the sake of
for value and for right I'm gonna be a
guy that will do whatever it takes for
people I know and love to help them keep
things together
because I'm a unifier not a blower upper
you see the difference there
I do and it's kind of there's there's
one thing where you said where it's kind
of conflicting so I'm hoping you can
kind of help me at library a little bit
you got it about about blowing up the
other family or other marriages
like to me it feels like if they didn't
make those decisions that it's not me
blowing it up it's them blowing it up
they are but you don't get a vote
yeah
it's almost as though you are running
around looking for places to insert
righteousness into it
and they didn't ask you for that
that makes that makes you visually ante
the greatest gift you can give is to be
an epicenter of such outrageous insane
peace
that when not if but when things get off
the rails in your friend's marriages
when things get off the rails in your
friends lives
they go to one person that instantly
something goes sideways like I gotta
call Eric
I'm over my head I'm about to respond to
this text I'm about to DM this person I
gotta call Eric
and if they create worlds where don't
tell Eric don't tell Eric hey don't
invite Eric because Eric's gonna be on
radar alert looking for who's screwing
up per his judgment
that's not the influence that's the
influential man has
but an influence of now everybody knows
where Eric stands
and everybody knows that Eric loves his
son like we've never seen a father love
a son ever
that guy's always hugging that kid that
guy's always kissing that kid that guy's
always looking him in the eyes and
saying thank God Almighty that I get to
be your dad
never see anything like it
and then when their marriages get in
trouble
they holler at you
see the difference man
yeah
it's a total shift
uh so I kind of I have a question about
that like
because during this conversation has
kind of felt like a big
it feels like a big
you know suitcase of angers and taken
off my shoulders
but at the same time it's like
I just really want to treat my mom a lot
better and I'm just not sure I'm not
sure how to do it if it's in my place to
do it so now you're talking
so you're a kind of guy that honors his
mom beyond what even makes sense
you're not a guy that tries to fix her
marriage because she's a grown woman she
can do whatever she wants
but you're a son do you all live in the
same town
I'm sorry y'all live in the same town
oh yes okay you are a son this is an
identity I'm a son who takes my mom on a
breakfast date
with me and her grandson once a week we
never miss
I'm a guy who once a week on Friday
evenings me and my four-year-old son we
make a card out of construction paper
and glue and whatever wood nails we make
Grandma one present a week
52 weeks 52 presents a year
and now you're not a your identity isn't
I'm not I'm a God that makes sure every
marriage is perfect even though you got
a kid you're not married right I'm gonna
make sure every that's not my identity
my identity is I'm gonna be
s I'm gonna honor my mom
to the point where she has to look in
the mirror and say oh my goodness this
is what love looks like
I am worth more than this
and that's what you can control the
relationship from your side to your mom
you can control your identity you see
the difference there man
yeah I I definitely do it's
my mom and I we've had a we've had a
rocky relationship especially when I was
a teenager and of course you know
classic guys when you're 18 19 you think
you know everything and yes you get
older honestly the best thing for her
and I ever was when I moved out of state
and then I moved back a few years later
her and I we grew a lot closer every
time there's a great uh I think it's a
Mark Twain quote which is when I was 14
my dad was the stupidest man on the
planet
I'm butchering the quote but when I was
14 my dad was the dumbest man in the in
in on the planet and then when I came
back home at the age of 21 I was stunned
at how much my dad had learned in seven
years all right
you got some sense and got some wisdom
and I got I got some bad news for you
the bad news is
as knuckleheaded as you were at 18 and
19 you know you're 28 and you can see
that with such wisdom and Clarity my
promise is that doubles when you're 38
looking back at 28 year old self
the things you think are right and
perfect and this is the way
at 28 I promise when you turn 40 you're
like oh man I was way off way off
and I want to take you mentioned that
that suitcase of anger
when you were at a party and you were
hyper vigilantly is that everybody say
that scanning the room to make sure
everybody's doing right
you know who that's that that pains and
hurts you it's exhausting
all the energy you spent trying to fix
your parents marriage that they didn't
ask you to fix all the energy you spent
being pissed off at your dad for all
these years that just weighs down you it
doesn't change their behavior doesn't
fix their marriage it just weighs down
you and you got a four-year-old little
boy that's looking next at looking up at
you at all times absorbing you
and his one question is why is Dad so
angry all the time
why is Dad so angry it must be me I'm
gonna try to fix it
I need him to see me
because if he can just see me he won't
be so angry and that's how this thing
goes in a cycle and a cycle and a cycle
and a cycle
and I have no doubt in my mind Eric
you're gonna be the guy that breaks that
cycle for your family
you're gonna break it
stops with me which means I don't carry
anger anymore
except for one or two or three very big
Hills that I'm gonna die on I'll dial
those every time no question about it
but when it comes to the guy who was
just driving down the road when I was
getting here this morning with a
ponytail and his and he's got he's got a
license plates that are vanity plates
that said Hollywood
he cut me off
my first impulse just started laughing
a few years ago my first impulse would
have been I'm gonna smash the back of
your car and create a huge pile up I'll
show you
and of course I was just talking crap
and I wouldn't do any of those things
and by the time I got to work I would be
real close to a stroke slash heart
attack slash diarrhea all three of them
my body would just be like we're just
gonna shut everything down so all I have
to say is this
stop torturing my friend Eric
my friend Eric has is an amazing guy
he's done some amazing things and he's
making some extraordinary changes
stop carrying the anger
stuck here in the anchor
be very intentional I want you to write
down your new identities I'm a guy
who is about keeping marriages together
not making sure that they're all right
I'm a guy who will honor his mom I'm a
guy who will create a peaceful
non-acious home for my son
now you're talking
family tree changing ways of being
and on the line I'm gonna send you a
copy of own your past change your future
I want you to read that brother and that
will walk you through all that crap
you've been through and then give you a
path out my man thank you so much for
the call we'll be right back
this show is sponsored by better help
folks take a minute to think about how
much time you spend on yourself it's
easy to get caught up in what people
need from you and want from you and
never think about what you need and then
you end up too stretched out burned out
all of the madness of our current world
resting on your shoulders
look sometimes I put my head down to
work and then realize I haven't had a
meaningful conversation with my wife and
kids all day I get focused on what I'm
doing and I'm running and running and
running
and I don't know how to come back
and therapy is a great way to learn new
skills that make you the best version of
yourself to help you set boundaries and
still have energy left to help others
without leaving yourself behind so if
you're thinking of starting therapy give
better help a try it's totally online to
fit into your schedule you just fill out
a brief questionnaire to get matched
with a licensed therapist and you can
switch therapists at any time for no
additional charge so find more balance
find Wellness with better help visit
betterhelp.com deloney today to get 10
off your first month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash deloni
all right we're back let's go out to
let's go back to Canada and talk to
Chantelle with a pretty face what's up
Chantel
Hi how are you partying what are you up
to
a party I just lied to you I just
straight lied to you on my show sorry
I'm not I'm just at work let's let's
figure it out dude what's up
um so four years ago I was a cyclist hit
by a truck
um very very injuries yeah yikes the
process to heal both uh legal and
medically
um are still ongoing so for four very
long years
um the length of time passing is just
like picking an old wound over and over
and over again when I just want to heal
and get past it
how can I rebuild my resilience when
time and obligations keep beating me
down
how honest can I be with you
Barry you're not gonna like it Chantelle
can we still be friends I'm used to
tough realities do what
I'm very used to tough realities
okay
the moment you decide I'm gonna stop
trying to get past all of this
and instead shift your body energy and
your focus to I'm gonna metabolize this
as this is my life this is a part of my
one tiny little precious life
then resilience can begin to do its work
and grow roots in you
right now you have a electric leaf
blower and you keep blowing the soil off
and The Roots can't take hold because
you're waiting for this thing to be over
you keep cleaning it all off
you've been through hell
what are some of your injuries involved
in this rack
oh
uh double two types of brain bleed
double pneumothoax broken ribs
um I almost lost my left leg I had to
relearn how to walk
I have an ostomy I had to have bladder
surgery I probably will never be able to
get pregnant
pretty pretty awful
and how has the
medical system navigating that mess in
Canada been
amazing like I have
um Accent Hair excuse me excellent
Healthcare and excellent support
and even though you know covid for some
surgeries take a long time to get around
to me because I was no longer emergent
after you know you're patched up enough
to be alive
um I've gotten surgeries that have
increased my quality of life which I'm
thankful for wonderful
um what about the legal mess
oh God the legal mess is a mess up here
in Canada we have a process known as the
catastrophic process when you have
injuries as severe as mine
um and it's just long you know it's
going to take a long time to settle
because they're looking forward in my
life and the quality of my life you know
10 20 years from now and what these
injuries mean since they're so
life-altering so that's still ongoing
okay
what have you done in the last four
years to begin to
re-imagine and live your life
I haven't been able to
um I've been in it like it's been four
long years as uh five or six
appointments a week legal or medical
multiple surgeries we're talking seven
to eight surgeries who's paying your
bills
our Medical
clothes what about your rent oh you're
back at work okay yeah
I went back to work yeah okay good for
you yeah
so
resilience is not something you can
think your way to
resilience is a scratching and clawing
one centimeter at a time one inch at a
time
and you look back
without thinking you turn your head and
you realize you have crawled and
scratched and clawed a mile
and you're not scrolling you're not
scratching and clawing anymore you're
suddenly you're you're crawling on all
fours
and then you look up and you've got
another mile
and you've got calluses on your hands
and on your feet and on your knees
and then you put one foot down and you
stand up
see what I'm saying resilience is formed
on one step after one step after one
step
not on this idea that I'm past all of
this
and what I promise you I promise you
you are stronger than you could possibly
imagine
Chantelle you got hit by a truck
and you and I are still talking
yeah I'm I'm lucky to be here and I I
acknowledged that and I accept it hold
on hold on hold on hold on you're lucky
to be here yes period move that over to
the side you are a gangster you're a
badass you're still here
you're not giving Chantelle the credit
Chantelle deserves
I feel like I've mentally accepted that
though like that was then and this is
four years later and I want more there
we go tell me what do you want
I mean I used to run marathons okay and
I was was an ecstatic person are you
ever gonna be able to run a marathon
again
no okay
we have to grieve that that's a
significant loss
that is a heartbreaking loss that is you
sitting down and writing a letter to
Chantelle the marathon runner Remember
When
and now those days are over
this is sitting with a couple of
girlfriends that you really really trust
and having written a letter to Future
Chantelle
to let her know we may not have babies
and that was a part of our ride dude
that was going to be part of it
it's sitting in that ugly
and being I feel like I've been sitting
in the ugly for too long and I just want
to go like you can but I don't think
you're I don't I I think you sat in the
mess but there's some intentionality you
sat in it but there's there's work right
so if you if your sewer
uh here here at my house I live out in
the woods here so I've got a septic tank
it's not connected to the Sewer right I
can go sit in the septic tank if it's if
it's got a if it's broken it's
disgusting I can't think of a grosser
thing to do I'd go sit in my septic tank
I can sit there for years
but there's there's nothing productive
that I've done I've done any of the work
and if I try to go back inside my house
my wife would be like get away from my
front porch
and I'd end up just outside I end up in
the wilderness right
so there's something about using the
being intentional in the Darkness
instead of just sitting in it and then
wishing I wasn't in it anymore I don't
want you in it either
but I also want you to to with both
hands grab a hold of reality
and that's so hard man because this
wreck took everything from you it took
your passions it took your future took
this this picture you had of what a
family might look like you're gonna have
a family that's gonna look different but
this is what this picture was going to
look like and here's the process and it
took that from you
that's a that's a that's a stone cold
reality that happened
and then what comes next
so you can't you can't run marathons
what's next
I don't know I'm trying to figure that
out no you gotta say it you've thought
of something you've looked it up on the
internet during one of your Dark Nights
of the Soul what is it
I haven't maybe I'm just too stuck on
what was
part of the healing process part of part
of the counseling you know with
therapists and physios has been I think
we gotta let it go maybe you gotta find
a new passion but I don't know how
I haven't found something that breathes
the same light to my soul yet
there was a moment years before you ran
a merit your first marathon
when like my seven-year-old little girl
just takes off running through the yard
and her little blonde hair is flying all
backwards and she's running so slow but
she thinks she is running a thousand
miles an hour
she can run for about 50 yards before
she's sucking wind can't breathe
and that was the Genesis
of her wanting to run more and more and
there was a moment when that was you
it was a few steps that put wind in your
hair
and put a smile on your face and over
time that turned into marathons
what you have to be willing to do the
The Bravery you've got in your guts the
Courage the moment of Courage you've got
in front of you is this
I gotta take a few steps towards
something
with one day I might be able to run a
marathon whatever that looks like I'm
gonna pick up a guitar and I'm gonna
figure out how to play this thing
because one day I might play live
I am going to start a women's group for
people who get hit by trucks and it's
going to be awkward and weird and so
uncomfortable because one day I might
help heal families
I'm going to start the adoption process
you see what I'm saying
yep
I can't tell you how bad the world needs
you let's take another step
just in a New Direction
are you in
I'm in
here's your first two steps I want you
to write Chantelle the the athlete the
runner a letter
and tell her what an honor it was to do
life with her how much fun you all had
how many Adventures you went on and then
to as you end that letter the last half
page the last two pages
let her know and life threw us a
curveball
actually life hit us with like a truck
and now we're gonna have to make some
changes and it's been an honor
and we're gonna do something different
now
and that's not going to be the insta
cure but what we're going to begin to do
is teach our body that that was then and
that was a part of me that will always
be a part of me and that part is that
season is over
and now what's going to come next
and I promise you if you spend some time
maybe you can't see it but sit with a
couple of girlfriends and say we gotta
come up with 10 things and I gotta try
them I gotta take 50 yard dash in 10
different directions not literally but
figuratively 50 yard dash knee in either
direction remember seven-year-old
Chantel running for the first time just
sprinting her little heart out
what's that next step
resilience is not something you can just
wake up in half it's something that you
find it's a strength and strength comes
from pushing against heavy things
against resistance
that's where strength comes from
I
promise you you're worth it
I promise you
promise you
be right back
[Music]
it seems so easy but most of us way
undervalue real genuine relationships
our friendships our marriages we don't
know what we're doing and instead of
diving into the mess we accept
shallowness and distraction and we
wallpaper over our loneliness so let me
say this boldly you cannot be well alone
you've got to get connected to real life
people and have deep powerful
relationships I'm talking about
relationships where you can be honest
where you can open up where you can
share hard things and you each know that
you'll still show up for each other and
in my new book own your past change your
future we'll walk through a not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness and getting
connected is a key part of that that's
why you'll learn shallowness and
loneliness are so dangerous and more
importantly you'll learn how to create
meaningful relationships in your life
moving forward there is no good app to
help adults find friendships but this
book can help go to John deloney.com to
take the next step towards Wellness
that's own your past change your future
at John deloney.com
all right as we wrap up today's show we
are starting a new way that we're going
to end the show for for a minute for a
little bit
and I don't I'm gonna call it the
opinion of the day not the song of the
day John's opinion of the day all right
Kelly you were just telling me Google
searches are at an all-time high for
what uh where do I make friends and how
do I make friends they're seeing uh just
astronomical jumps in Google searches
for those two things how do I make
friends and where do I make friends
where do I make friends
John deloney's opinion of the day stop
Googling that question and just go go
just ask three weirdos from work over to
your house and don't clean up don't
clean up tell them just bring whatever
you think well Kelly needs to clean up
because let's let's be honest but like
I'm just saying you're it's weird
I'm like an OCD neat freak
I know except you're getting tattoos and
you're not OCD about those but listen go
make friends go find some people at work
find some people at yourself in your
softball league and if you don't have
one of those join it you know you got
some bro Downs at the gym y'all go hang
out it's like hey you want to go eat
drink protein shakes together and just
like rub protein powder in our hair I
don't know what you're gonna do go to
church go whatever it is stop
Googling these freaking questions go be
weird go first go first
you are not gonna find making friend
life change on Google
the four steps to making friends just go
is gonna be awkward you're gonna get
rejected you're gonna get denied it's
gonna suck you're gonna feel like a
loser and go again and go again and go
again
and my promise to you is
if you will go out and be fully all you
just your weird little self
you'll end up with two or three people
or four people who are all in
until one of them votes weird and then
y'all can make fun of them and then you
are all friends again
and then one of them will get married
somebody will have their ninth kid
whatever happens and they may fade away
that's part of life stop Googling this
question just go just go you know you
gotta just go just go listen you are
worth having friends and you're worth
being friends with I love you guys this
is the I was gonna say I I forgot the
name of the show peace out y'all stay in
school don't do drugs
[Music]